Oh
you know there's this idea floating
around which I totally buy it's this
notion that we are already cyborgs you
know people are so dystopian when they
think about the future of technology
would they fail to realize is that we
have been in a feedback loop in a self
amplifying feedback loop with our
technology since the origin of language
and stone tools for Christ sakes we use
our technologies to extend the
boundaries of what we are our tools are
our exoskeletons they are scaffoldings
extending our thought reach and vision
as Andy Clarke says there's a book by
Andy Clarke called natural born cyborgs
and him and David Chalmers they coined
the extended mind thesis which is this
idea that were literally extending the
boundaries of the human mind with these
technologies our smartphones are
extensions of our cognition they are
examples of distributed intelligence
iPhone therefore I am I mean literally
this idea that that our second skin is
our technology it's our turtle shell
it's our exoskeleton is is historic
blurs the boundary of sort of saying
that there's nature and then there's
technology and that in fact it's all on
a continuum and we just smack in the
middle between the Bourne and the made
as Kevin Kelley says but even Nietzsche
used to say man is a bridge and not an
end
towards self extension our technologies
become part of our skin we must get over
our skin bag bias the biological skin
bag is just one membrane our cells have
membranes too but our body is still a
part of us and our tools are a part of
us we transcend membranes we extend
ourselves that's what we do we are
already cyborgs